183 people on an Amtrak train have been
stranded for more than 36 hours after
that train hit a tree on the tracks in
the Pacific Northwest the train was
heading from Seattle to Los Angeles on
Sunday when it stopped very abruptly in
a remote area near Oak Ridge Oregon no
one was hurt here this morning
passengers on board say food carts are
empty parents with young children have
run out of diapers
usually it's a pretty uneventful ride
over mountain passes snowing last night
train took some damage and guess what
winter weather has hampered the efforts
to get the train moving again and snow
in the area made it impossible to
evacuate the passengers the statement
Union Pacific said crews are in the
process of clearing the track this
morning the Train will then move back to
Eugene in Portland I saw an interview
with someone who was on the train she
said the most frustrating thing other
than being stranded of course is that
they're not getting any information on
the train they're getting a lot from
social media and people calling but to
be there not knowing exactly what's
going on is extremely frustrated about
them yeah I got them